Bengie stopping he says men can't handle
the pain of being a woman man that's who
a male birth control study from 2012 is
making waves online this week after it
came out that the men involved in the
trial had to drop out because they
couldn't handle the side effects like
acne changes in libido and mood swings
well well well
we're all that shape men almost had
their own highly effective birth control
but the medical trial had to stop when
some of the men said they couldn't take
the side effects but those side effects
were almost identical to what women have
been dealing with for decades we're
talking depression muscle pain mood
swings and right stop enough enough okay
you don't want that sound our folks may
be physiologically we're just not used
to that stuff okay or maybe maybe we
just don't appreciate your tone Helen I
mean we could continue this conversation
but you know we don't feel like talking
about this right now until you feel like
listening god damnit I'm so hungry but I
don't know what I want to eat no no no
just stop I'm not I'm not taking these
pills anymore just so you can finish in
me okay it's not worth it
to stop it I need my life back